[Applaus]
[Musik]
estland 1991 nach mehr als 50 jahren
sowjetischer besatzung und
kommunistischer diktatur erlangt er ist
land seine unabhängigkeit zurück das
erbe der kommunistischen ära waffe die
ersten die für alle anderen länder der
ehemaligen sowjetunion
katastrophal im jahr 1991 lag das
bruttoinlandsprodukt pro kopf bei
weniger als 3500 us-dollar was in
heutiger zeit ländern wie bolivien oder
el salvador entspricht das schlimmste
stand aber natürlich noch bevor der
verfall des sowjet blogs war ein harter
schlag für seine mitgliedsländer und
estland bildete dabei wahrlich keine
ausnahme im jahr 1992 schrumpfte die
wirtschaft des baltischen staates um
mehr als 20 prozent es war an der zeit
ein neues staatsmodell aufzubauen und
dieses vorhaben meine lieben zuschauer
haben die ersten sehr sehr ernst
genommen während einige der neuen
splitter staaten der sowjetunion wie die
ukraine usbekistan und weißrussland in
instabilität in krisen und den
autokratie versanken verlegt die
geschichte estlands völlig anders
[Musik]
heute ist es land eines der
wohlhabendsten länder der welt sein
potenzial ist immens unseren
lebensstandard verbessert sich ständig
im jahr 2020 lag das kaufkraftbereinigt
pro kopf bip estlands bei 40.000 us
dollar womit es länder die spanien
bereits überholt hat
und das ist noch nicht alles die
entwicklung praktisch aller
makroökonomischen parameter über trifft
nicht nur die spaniens sondern auch die
der mehrheit der übrigen eu-länder bei
weitem so ist es beispielsweise eines
jener länder mit den gesündesten
öffentlichen haushalten der welt und hat
im verhältnis zu seiner bevölkerung die
höchste unternehmer quote aller
europäischen länder jedes jahr werden
mehr als 20 unternehmen pro 1000
einwohner gegründet das ist sechs mal
mehr als der eu durchschnitt und so ist
es land zur europäischen euro pro nation
schlechthin geworden so was wie ein
kleines und ja einiges silicon valley
der eu allerdings stellt sich die frage
wie sie eine solche arten vorraum der
entwicklung in so kurzer zeit
hinbekommen konnten was ist das
geheimnis hinter den estnischen modell
was sind die zutaten für ihren erfolg
[Musik]
oh
ja darüber haben wir bereits ein video
gedreht und die werde es natürlich für
dich in der beschreibung und verlinken
wir können mehrere faktoren hervorheben
von der steuerpolitik bis hin zur
engagierten technologiepolitik einer der
wichtigsten faktoren für den erfolg ist
lang es ist allerdings auch das
bildungssystem du weißt ist vielleicht
nicht und hätte es mir nie vorstellen
können aber estland hat das beste
bildungssystem
europas das land selbst sind sich stolz
die bildungs nation aber möchtest du
wissen was das besondere an seinem
bildungssystem ist was genau sind seine
wichtigsten merkmale was ist das
bildungs geheimnis estlands dass dieses
land zu einem unikum und großem vorbild
macht nun genau das werden wir euch in
diesem video verraten bevor wir jedoch
zur tat schreiten müssen wir uns alle
bei unserem sponsor bedanken der erst
das heutige video ermöglicht hat georges
art wie gehen wenn wir nämlich ein
sponsoring angebot annehmen muss ist
schon um etwas gehen von dem wir selbst
denken dass es für unsere zuschauer eine
wirklich sinnvolle dienstleistung
darstellt und eine sichere vpn dass
weder datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lot ist für uns
alle ganz bestimmt etwas hochgradig
sinnvoll denn anonymität und sicherheit
ms sind ein immer kostbares gut und wir
alle sollten so viel wie möglich dafür
tun deswegen müssen wir euch unbedingt
den überaus verlässlichen und bewerten
wie die and service vom surf stark ans
herz legen search art bietet unzählige
sicherheitsfeatures zum beispiel clean
web dass alle cookies pop aus und auch
fortgeschrittene identifizierungs und
nachverfolgung mechanismen von denen man
oft gar nichts art sicher bloggt und die
damit verbundenen gefahren beseitigt
natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe auf
websites und internet dienste zugreifen
die in dem land in dem ihr alle seid
nicht verfügbar sind ohne zensur und
logging ob daheim oder im urlaub mit
flex und andere streaming dienste die
ihre inhalte nur in den usa anbieten von
europa aus nutzen mit surfer kein
problem aber nicht nur das mit nur einem
surf comfort könnt ihr alle eure geräte
im bpm registrieren handys notebooks
oder sogar ihren smart tvs liegt
wirklich alle arten von geräten ab ihr
bekommt damit einen lückenlosen schutz
so und wenn ihr den rabattcode
politik.de angebt bekommt ihr von surft
auf einen rabatt in höhe von 83 prozent
und obendrein die ersten drei monate
gratis dazu den link zu diesem angebot
findet ihr in der beschreibung unter
diesem video also nichts wie los besorgt
euch so schlag und greift damit
gleichzeitig auch uns finanziell unter
die arme das könnt ihr übrigens auch
direkt mit hilfe des paypal spenden
links den ich ebenfalls in die
beschreibung gepackt haben wir sind euch
für jede unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hätten wir uns euch in zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere videos zu
liefern so und nun lasst uns schnell
wieder zum thema dieses videos
zurückkommen und zur beantwortung
unserer frage was ist das große bildungs
geheimes estlands was hat dieses land
zum vorbild für europa und die ganze
welt gemacht also los geht's
[Musik]
klasse statt masse qualität statt
quantität
der erfolg des estnischen bildungsmodell
es ist keine ansichtssache sondern wird
von allen institutionen bestätigt die
sich mit der bewertung der verschiedenen
bildungssystemen befassen darunter
natürlich auch die pisa studie laut pisa
ist nicht nur in europa führen sondern
in der ganzen welt nach singapur ist das
kleine baltische land der spitzenreiter
in allen drei grundkompetenzen lesen
mathematik und naturwissenschaften
und das ist noch lange nicht das ende
dieser erfolgsgeschichte hier ein paar
fakten das land hat den weltweit
höchsten prozentsatz an leistungsstarken
schülern aus einkommensschwachen
familien
es weist auch die geringsten bildungs
unterschiede zwischen stadt und land auf
außerdem haben sie die niedrigsten
quoten an schülern ohne grundbildung nur
fünf prozent und eine der niedrigsten
durchfallquoten in der ganzen oecd und
als ob das noch nicht genug wäre stehen
sie auch bei den
fremdsprachenkenntnissen an erster
stelle
[Musik]
ja meine lieben zuschauern estland läuft
der soziale fahrstuhl auf hochtouren
bislang hat mittlerweile selbst das
finnische bildungssystem überholt
welches bis jetzt der maßstab für
bildung in europa wie also haben sie das
geschafft ich weiß genau was viele von
euch denken werden klar gegeben sicher
eine menge geld für bildung aus und
dieses geld kommt bestimmt aus
eu-subventionen nun ein falls du das
denkst liegst du total falsch
[Musik]
ja island unternimmt erhebliche
anstrengungen im bildungsbereich aber
die öffentlichen ausgaben pro schüler
sind bei weitem nicht die höchsten in
der oecd auch nicht wenn wir die
ausgaben um die unterschiede bei preisen
und löhnen bereinigen in der tat gibt es
viele länder mit viel höheren ausgaben
pro schüler und dennoch viel
schlechteren ergebnissen möchtest du ein
beispiel nun wie wäre es mit spanien
wie du siehst ist dann trotz der mit
abstand besten bildungsergebnisse weit
davon entfernt in island zu sein das am
meisten für bildung pro schüler aus gibt
tatsächlich liegen die ausgaben weit
unter dem oecd und eu durchschnitt
selbst wenn man die
kaufkraftunterschiede berücksichtigt und
deswegen sollten wir eines immer wieder
betonen und unseren politikern immer
wieder ins gedächtnis rufen nein liebe
politiker man kann ein problem nicht
dadurch lösen dass man einfach hirnlos
nur einen haufen geld drauf werft und
auch das bildungssystem nur mit kohle
zuzuschütten ist kein erfolgsrezept wenn
es so einfach wäre würde es reichen
immer mehr und mehr für bildung
auszugeben um immer bessere ergebnisse
zu erzielen und allen ländern davon zu
allen die realität sieht jedoch ganz
anders aus das haben erfahrungen aus
unzähligen ländern gezeigt es geht nicht
darum wie viel ausgegeben wird sondern
vor allem darum wie die mittel verwendet
werden schauen wir uns noch mal kurz ein
anderes beispiel an
[Musik]
island gibt pro schüler viel mehr geld
aus als estland und ich wiederhole das
gilt sogar unter berücksichtigung der
unterschiede bei gehältern und preisen
wenn wir also der politischen logik
folgen das mehrausgaben bessere
ergebnisse bedeuten dann müsste ich dann
ein viel besseres bildungssystem haben
als estland aber überraschungen es zeigt
sich nicht nur dass estland gegenüber
island klar der wind sondern auch dass
island laut pisa zu den ländern mit der
schlechtesten performance in ganz europa
gehört viel geld auszugeben meine liebe
soll politik zuschauer ist keine
garantie für qualität das wissen wie
hier bei visual politik auch nur zu gut
aber nachdem wir nun wissen dass nicht
alles nur eine frage des geldes ist was
haltet ihr davon wenn er gleich zur
sache kommen und uns die wichtigsten
aspekte des nächsten bildungssystems
ansehen was können wir von den ersten
lernen also aufgepasst
[Musik]
die säulen des mission wohlstands
ok visa-politik fans macht euren kopf
für eine wahl frei denn das
bildungsmodell über das versprechen
werden hat wenig damit zu tun was wir
aus anderen ländern kennen wir werden
überall bildungsmodell sprechen dass
merkwürdigerweise nicht die politischen
interessen untergeordnet ist sondern dem
tatsächlichen bedarf an humankapital in
einer modernen welt natürlich
einschließlich der welt t realwirtschaft
wie bitte ein bildungssystem das
komplett so gestaltet ist dass die
schüler nach ihrem abschluss schnell
einen hoch qualifizierten job finden
können weil sie einfach genau das
gelernt haben was man dafür mitbringen
muss das hört sich ja fast schon
verrückt an nun ja die ersten haben wir
bildungssystem doch tatsächlich zu einer
tragenden säule ihrer
wirtschaftsstrategie gemacht die große
frage lautet nun also wie genau
unterscheidet sich das biblische
bildungsmodell von dem anderer länder
nun der erste schlüssel zu dessen
verständnis liegt in der unabhängigkeit
der unabhängigkeit der schulen und der
lehrer
[Musik]
in estland müssen sich zwar alle schulen
an einen von der regierung festgelegten
rahmenprogramm mit mindestanforderungen
halten aber die spielräume deren
umsetzung ist sehr liberal und jede
schule geht es ist gut und sogar jede
lehrkraft kann sowohl den endgültigen
lehrplan als auch die didaktische
methodik selbst bestimmen
[Musik]
und all jenen bedenkenträgern die jetzt
einwenden dass sowas doch die schule und
lehrkräfte überfordern die
vergleichbarkeit der schüler zerstören
und im chaos enden würde kann ich nur
entgegen stellt euch vor das geradezu
wohl die schulen als auch die lehrer als
allererste daran interessiert waren dass
das alles reibungslos funktioniert unter
anderem wegen des dualen modell ist der
öffentlichen finanzierung des estnischen
bildungssystems und um was für ein
duales modell handelt es sich hier bitte
nun dass sie den islam folgendermaßen
aus es gibt kaum privatschulen und
trotzdem sind die staatlichen schulen
einem intensiven das modell unterworfen
denn einerseits folgt die finanzierung
der schulen einer philosophie welche
kompetitive marktmechanismen und
prozessor unterstützt indem die
finanzierung an der schule von der zahl
der schüler abhängt welche diese schule
an zu ziehen vermag die attraktiver ihr
angebot und je mehr schüler sie anzieht
desto mehr mittel erhält sie
andererseits werden die didaktischen
leistungen und angebote jeder schule
ständig bewertet und die ergebnisse
vollständig veröffentlicht dadurch
entsteht eine vollkommen transparente
wettbewerbsdynamik bei der die eltern
ihre kinder an den besten schulen
anmelden können dieser prozess erhöht
auch den druck auf die schulleitungen
und lehrkörper jener schulen mit den
schlechtesten leistungen so dass sie
sich mehr anstrengen müssen sonst gehen
sie unter
[Musik]
dadurch werden schlendrian und einem
weiter so bereits systemisch verhindert
und nicht noch wie in anderen ländern
gefördert es geht eben nicht nur darum
dass die besten schulen und hochschulen
gefragter sind einen besseren ruf haben
und dadurch mehr ressourcen bekommen
sondern das gute ergebnisse ganz einfach
ihr überleben garantieren denn eine der
größten herausforderungen ist lang ist
die demographie in den letzten 15 jahren
ist die zahl der schüler im land um 40
prozent zurückgegangen was die regierung
wo die gemeinden dazu gezwungen hat
überzählige schulen zu schließen
allerdings werden nur die schulen den
schlechtesten ergebnissen geschlossen du
kannst sie also vorstellen welche
vitales interesse sowohl die schulen als
auch die lehrkräfte daran haben ihre
ergebnisse zu verbessern und mehr
schüler zu gewinnen im übrigen muss an
dieser stelle gesagt werden dass die
schulleitung jeder schule ein sehr hohes
maß an autonomie hat wenn es zb darum
geht zu entscheiden welche lehrkräfte
sie einstellen wie hoch die gehälter der
lehrkräfte sind und wie sie die mittel
verteilen die sie von der regierung
erhalten
[Musik]
ja genau die gehälter der lehrkräfte in
estland nicht an allen schulen gleich
und werden auch nicht durch einen
tarifvertrag festgelegt sie werden von
den schulen selbst bestimmt je mehr
mittel eine bildungseinrichtung erhält
desto höhere gehälter kann sie natürlich
zahlen das ist einfach das ergebnis des
wettbewerbs außerdem kann sich jede
bildungseinrichtung durch die größere
autonomie stärker von anderen
unterscheiden sich ausdifferenzieren in
wien sie sich auf verschiedene bereiche
spezialisiert kunst wirtschaft
wissenschaft und so weiter und so fort
es gibt sogar so genannte eliteschulen
eine schulart die darauf ausgelegt ist
alle fähigkeiten der begabtesten schüler
maximal zu fördern eine sache die in
manchen ländern leider schon ideologie
bedingt unmöglich scheint so werden dort
aber die besten talente durch
gleichmacherei erstickt anstatt ihnen
alle möglichkeiten zur verfügung zu
stellen ihr potenzial auch zum wohle der
ganzen gesellschaft und des ganzen
landes optimal zu entfalten aber das ist
noch nicht das ende der fahnenstange
auch die lehrkräfte haben höhere
anforderungen und mehr verantwortung als
in anderen ländern
ein schüler zb über einen längeren
zeitraum schlechte leistungen erbringen
kann die lehrkraft sogar entlassen
werden damit es aber nicht soweit kommt
erhalten estnische lehrkräfte eine
intensive fortbildung die es ihnen
ermöglicht ihr wissen ihre inhalte und
ihre lehrmethode zu verbessern und
aufzufrischen es handelt sich um eine
intensive und obligatorischen ford-pilot
wie viele vorteile mit sich bringt zum
beispiel die anpassung an neue
technologien
[Applaus]
im gegenzug haben lehrer jedoch auch
mehr pädagogische freiheit und einfluss
auf alle entscheidungen zb sagen ganze
83 prozent der estnischen schulleiter
dass lehrkräfte eine wichtige rolle bei
aufgaben die der gestaltung der
schulpolitik des lehrplans und der
unterrichtsmethoden spiel in dieser
hinsicht ist das baltische land doppelt
so gut wie der oecd durchschnitt von 42
prozent ist das nicht erstaunlich alles
wirklich alles in essen das
bildungsmodell basiert auf inklusion und
wettbewerb zugleich und vergisst nicht
dass wir hier über einen wesentlichen
staatliches system sprechen für den
anderen ländern leid geplagten eltern
schüler und lehrer muss die schon fast
unwirklich erscheinen gut an dieser
stelle fragst du dich vielleicht okay
aber wie sieht eigentlich die ethischen
lehrpläne aus und haben sie etwas damit
zu tun dass so viele absolventen zu
erfolgreichen unternehmensgründern
werden genau da schaute uns jetzt mal an
[Musik]
gemeinsam zum erfolg
ich habe es zu beginn des videos bereits
erwähnt das estnische bildungsmodell ist
in erster linie auf die wirtschaft und
die vorbereitung auf die arbeitswelt
ausgerichtet so beteiligen sich zum
beispiel vertreter der zivilgesellschaft
und der unternehmen selbst an der
gestaltung unserer akademischen
programme und das ist nicht der einzige
bereich der zusammenarbeit bereits im
sekundar als auch im tertiärbereich gibt
es umfangreiche berufspraktika ds
estnischen schülern ermöglichen bereits
mit einiger erfahrung in den
arbeitsmarkt einzusteigen nach der
sekundarstufe 1 das heißt nach der
neunten klasse können die schüler
zwischen einer berufsbildenden schule
beziehungsweise beruflichen ausbildung
auf einer berufsschule oder eine
weiterführende schule das heißt der
sekundarstufe 2 auf einem gymnasium
wählen ohne eigentlich davon hat estland
jedoch praktika so stark einbezogen dass
eigentlich jeder dieser berufswege einer
berufsausbildung gleich kommt von der
sekundarstufe bis hin zum universitären
masterabschluss und wir reden hier nicht
von den typischen zwei bis vierwöchige
praktika nein die esstischen lehrpläne
und berufsbildungs programme beinhalten
praktika die bis zu 50 prozent der
wochenstunden ausmachen auf diese weise
wollen die esten jedes risiko eines
verplant ans werk voller ausbildungszeit
für praxisferne büffelei oder das
abdriften der schüler in von den
bedürfnissen der realen welt abgekoppelt
sphären schon im keim ersticken aber
abgesehen von der zusammenarbeit mit
unternehmen können wir eine weitere
besonderheit hervor heben die ersten
sind besessen von der gleichheit in
jeder bildungs phase ja ich weiß dass
bei manchen verhindern vielleicht die
alarmleuchten angefangen haben wie wild
zu blinken als ich die elitenförderung
erwähnt habe für viele ist dies ein
rotes tuch weil sie dadurch die anderen
schüler benachteiligt sehen aber keine
angst die esten haben auch dieses
problem auf sehr kluge weise gelöst denn
wenn ich von gleichheit spreche meine
ich nicht gleichmacherei in dem sinn
dass jeder einen abschluss bekommt egal
wie er performt nein echte gleichheit
bedeutet dass jeder die gleichen
bedingungen hat um voranzukommen
unabhängig von seinem sozioökonomischen
und bildungsumfeld mit anderen worten
gleichheit der chancen nicht der
ergebnisse
das bedeutet dass in estland nicht nur
die bildung vom staat bezahlt wird
einschließlich der universitäten sondern
auch die schulbücher und sogar die
cafeteria alle schüler die der
schulpflicht unterliegen erhalten in der
schule kostenlose mahlzeiten außerdem
haben alle bürger bis zum alter von 19
jahren anspruch auf eine kostenlose
krankenversicherung inklusive
kostenloser dental medizin
in den grundschulen führen
krankenschwestern regelmäßig kostenlose
routineuntersuchungen durch der
grundgedanke dabei ist dass alle schüler
unabhängig von ihrem sozioökonomischen
status in denen sie hineingeboren wurden
die gleichen chancen haben können nicht
mehr der bildungs level der eltern soll
darüber bestimmen welchen bildungsmittel
die kinder haben werden sondern einzig
und allein ihre eigenen talente kurz
gesagt womit wir es in island zu tun
haben sind wettbewerb spezialisierung
integration in wirtschaft und realwelt
und chancengleichheit in einem land mit
wenig bürokratie und niedrigen steuern
sich schlecht in das du nicht auch
natürlich ist auch dort nicht alles
perfekt denn obwohl ist das
bildungssystem heute mit abstand das
beste in europa ist gibt es immer noch
einige herausforderungen an denen die
ersten arbeiten die zwei wichtigsten
sind ein mangel an fachlehrern und die
verbesserung der schulischen leistungen
russischstämmiger schüler
[Musik]
wenn man jedoch die kompetenz und den
eifer der ersten in der vergangenheit
betrachtet denke ich dass die auch diese
probleme elegant lösen werben so das
waren die wichtigsten aspekte des
estnischen bildungsmodell des besten
bildungssystems in europa und einem der
besten in der ganzen welt dieses
bildungssystem ist eine der grundlagen
die es diesem land ermöglicht haben
nicht nur einen riesigen sprung in
sachen wohlstand so fortführen sondern
auch technologisch führend zu werden
eine brutstätte für startups das
europäisches silicon valley und die
letzte frage die uns bleibt ist nun
meinst du das auch dein land sich an der
estnischen erfolgsgeschichte orientieren
sollte welche der genannten elemente
würdest du gerne in deinem land
umgesetzt sehen wie immer sind wir auf
deine meinung zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe also dass dieses
video gefallen hat falls ja gebt uns
bitte einen like empfehle ist ein freund
und vergisst nicht das abo mit glück
keines unserer wg muss mehr zu verpassen
unterstütze unserer arbeit bitte auch
mit einer kleinen spende über den link
in der beschreibung unter diesem video
was gut und bis 8
[Musik]